welcome to today's live stream
we're going to be talking about
being solid in your own
presence in private
because the things that we do by
ourselves is more important than what we
do when we're around other people
and we feel like this is something that
strongly needs to be talked about
because we forget this
so
when we say
more important we're talking about for
our intensive purposes of this episode
obviously sitting in public is worse
than sitting in private
yes
yeah
all right so i got a question for you
before we go in
why do you think it's important
to
be solid
have integrity you know
have excellence it's on
when you're in private when no one's
watching because one might say that oh
there's no consequences if you do this
or you're slacking or you're you know
you're eating some oreos or no one's
looking
you know because no one's looking what's
the harm
so
the only thing i'm gonna say
is a quote that i had
seen a long time ago before i was muslim
and it was that like what you do
what you are rewarded for in public
is what you do in private
so just let that sink in
so someone who's successful let's say in
a business or in a sport or something
like they're successful because of what
they did in private all the training
and hours that they put in in private
on their own time like
they weren't forced to do it they did it
because
they chose to do that
right so the same can apply in
[Music]
all situations
so like you could you could be outside
saying like oh
and all that but then when you get in
in private you're over here
watching pornography
you're over here
just doing hadam things smoking weed
whatever it is and
you might even treat your family like
trash
because it's they're in private kind of
with you you know they're in the same
household as you
and uh they have kind of no choice but
to accept
who you are and what you do
unlike
the public unlike people outside of your
house
but yet
romney dog you got to say something
because i'm trying to story on our uh
t3m instagram that we're live
all right
uh yeah so basically what said
very very true
and um there's a hadith of the prophet
where he says
i'm going to paraphrase a little bit but
he says indeed i know of a type of
people from my nation so from the
muslims who would come on the day of
judgement with good deeds as big as
mountains
but allah will turn them into scattered
dust
and then they ask basically the prophet
saws
you know describe them to us you know
what what happened or what what are
these people what do they do because we
don't want to be from those people
and the prophet saws he said indeed
they are your brothers and they perform
acts of worship by night
in the same way you do but when they are
alone they transgress the limits of
allah
so the prophet said he describes
he describes the people who are muslim
who pray who fast they do the foreign
they are our brothers they sit amongst
us
and they they they walk with us they
pray with us
even at night
but when they're alone they transgress
the limits of allah and for that allah
will take all the good deeds that they
do in public in general
and make them into scattered dust and
basically make them worthless
it's very scary
bro
there's something on my mind it was like
a lot of the time we think that you know
how you hear like
you can lie to other people don't lie to
yourself
now what does that even mean
um
what that means at least the way i look
at it right now is
when you're by yourself you might think
no one's watching but you're watching
you're subconsciously letting yourself
down every time you fall into something
that you might not do when you're with
people if you do it when you're by
yourself one allah is watching just like
the other guy said but uh
more importantly but not more
importantly but i guess at least from a
personal point of view
your subconscious is is accepting that
you're doing this whether it's a sin
whether it's something that you're
slipping you're not supposed to be doing
it
you know you're doing it and you're
seeing yourself doing it so mentally you
already know you're you're deficient
there's a flaw there there's an
insufficiency
and whatever you tell yourself you still
took in you still acknowledge that you
did it
and then when you go about your day you
subconsciously carry on that that loss
that regret that resentment
that's true
yeah
you know i remember hearing once that i
think it was one in one shaykh who said
that you should strive you should work
to be
better in private than you are in public
like you should be more sincere in
private you should be better in private
you should do more good deeds at private
than you do in public and you should
avoid trying to be too you know
kind of
i don't say too pious but you know what
i mean like putting on too much of a
a pious acting or in public and it's i
guess it's it's profound because you
know
it really would help you avoid
these kinds of problems
because
as muslims as people in general actually
when we go out everyone has this natural
face that they put on like you at work
is different from you at school is
different from you
with your friends is different from you
alone at home
it's
all
different people they vary slightly but
the less you can get them to differ
the better
and the best
time for you to be the best is actually
when you're alone
because that's where you're most likely
to sit
and you can even see as that's when
you're most rewarded for for not sinning
because it's it's easy it's right there
it's you know it's whatever
it's facts
as facts i mean like people who struggle
with
us
the urges
they already said words that i wasn't
supposed to say didn't i
i mean that's fine bro what's done is
done it's a live stream you can't take
it back now
yeah you're right
um but people who struggle with uh
their natural urges and they're watching
this filth
what ends up happening is like it
happens in private
it doesn't happen in public like they're
not with their friends and then they
just
pull out their phones and then
pull the uh the tool that allah
subhanahu what the other has given them
and they just start
going at it right there with a friend
right next to them and the stuff for
allah they do that
they must have some some mental problem
or something
but like
it's all in private
it's all in private so that is the most
important time
we got to be on top of our game
um
and i agree there was a there was a chef
that was asked a question um
he was basically asking what is like a
quick way that i can stop sinning that i
can repel sins
and he said that you need to get married
and have kids
because when you have people under your
wing under your authority that's always
watching you right because you might
think oh i'm going to tell my son this
and then i'm going to do something else
bro they don't care if you tell them not
to cuss and you you're out there cussing
they're gonna cuss bro they don't care
what you said that you know don't cause
or if you say oh don't drink it's haram
they find liquor in your closet stuck
for allah what do you think they're
gonna do when they grow up
it's you're enabling them they're gonna
justify that oh daddy did it so i'm
gonna do it
anyway my example right here is
most important thing from what he said
was
you'll have people under your wing
you'll be the imam imam just doesn't
mean leader in prayer but their leader
right so they'll look up to you if
people look up to you you'll you'll be
more likely to set a good example
because you know the eyes are watching
you
um there was another video i think it
was by merciful servant it was saying
that if there was a camera that followed
you 24 7
and a mic that recorded everything you
said 24 7.
and it never got deleted would you
really be doing what you're doing
and uh obviously people would say no
but we are though
allah is watching us allah is listening
we think that you know nothing is is
forever no one's recording it
bro everything we do is being recorded
24 7.
in private in public wherever you name
it so the in private thing really
doesn't make a difference to me
i think it does make a difference
because it's like romney said like if
you can't align
who you are in private with who you are
in public
then you become
sincere
as to who you are because like bro if
you if you completely change up in
private and then you completely change
up again in public like what's the
difference
what's the difference bo
you know like it's it's not you anymore
it's not sincere
and it's like bro how can
imagine someone who is again i'm gonna
keep using this example is a very good
example not just someone who is
falling to their lusts
and they're watching this
these nasty things
online
but then imagine during the
the day in in public they're super pious
bro there's a huge disconnect that is
not a sincere individual
and if they're all right with that like
imagine how that bleeds into their
subconscious and everything else that
they do then they become they start to
become insincere with every other thing
that they do
in their life so i think it's very
important bro
100
okay do you remember uh comment from
brother yama
we have two angels on the side and they
write everything down 20 100
100 percent
um
there's something that a lot of people
might not be familiar with but when you
do sin i believe there's like a window
where if you repent the angels don't
write it down or something like that
um can you go a little deeper into that
honestly i remember hearing that once
but i i don't know much about about it
to be honest uh yes i know and even
i mean obviously if there is a window
if there's a you know that window then
we want to take advantage of it but
regardless whether it gets written down
by the angels or not
allah says in the quran whoever
commits a sin or transgresses in the
state of jahiliyyah the state of
ignorance and then repents soon after
allah will forgive them i mentioned this
before so i'm going to try and you know
quickly go through it
the scholars they say that when allah
says in the state of jahilya what he's
referring to is the state that people
are in when they sin or the state that
people are in when they like cheat on
their spouse because when you're
cheating on your spouse
yeah you're not thinking of them
right they're not on your mind so you're
in a state of being ignorant towards the
fact that you have a spouse so you can
actually be in a state of being ignorant
of allah and kind of being forgetful
when you're sitting because when you're
sinning you're not sitting being like
you know allah is watching me and you
know and if you do you most likely
you're you're gonna stop sinning because
that guilt that you feel
so
or hopefully you would but um
when you're in that state of sinning and
you know you know allah or you you
forget allah is watching you you're in
the state of jahilya
and then soon after the scholars say
that soon after means some time before
his death
so as long as you repent after and you
say you know
allah says
allah says you know tell my believing
servants tell my servant to transgress
against themselves by sinning don't
despair in the mercy of allah indeed
allah forgives all sins and it is him
who is the most forgiving the most
merciful
so whether there's a window or not
whether it's been 30 years or it's been
30 seconds
if you repent to allah sincerely then
allah and you are sincere that allah
will forgive you
insha allah
okay brother calabash but isn't it
better to be pious in public than only
in private
not exposing your sins to the public yes
not justifying standing in private
though
good question
you should be pious we're saying that
they should be aligned i mean that you
you shouldn't just be pies in public and
then not pious
in private
you know like you can't be all about the
quran and sunnah and islam and all that
in public but then when you're in
private there's no
queen in sunnah there's no islam
yeah yeah when the reason like if i were
if i were to say prioritize one over the
other
like you should be pious all the time
but if i were to say prioritize one and
focus on one i would say focus on the
private one more
because that's actually
i don't want to say it's a lot more
dangerous but you're a lot more
susceptible in private
because let's say you weren't a muslim
the chances of you doing certain things
in public go down already just because
you're in front of people
um now if you are a muslim you shouldn't
be doing anything anytime but you know
the chances of you going out and like
flirting with the girl or flirting with
a guy or something in public they go
down even more now imagine you're in
front of a guy in front of a girl a
woman alone
in your room
right the chances of you doing that go
up even higher now imagine you're alone
by yourself in your room the chances of
you you know doing the what you know
angel mentioned the example go up even
more so that's why i would say focus in
the private life because the hadith of
the process i mentioned before we don't
want to be the bankrupt people on the
day of judgement where we do good in
public and then in private we transgress
the limits of allah and allah causes all
the good deeds to go
like like a mountain that becomes dust
i'm going to continue
[Music]
on this day of jummah for your sadhaka
and i just want to say something real
quick that rami that's 100 facts and uh
a lot of people what they don't realize
is when you sin in private it's kind of
like what i said before um you kind of
lose self-respect we don't want to admit
this but we do you're basically telling
yourself that i actually don't have the
self-control that i thought i did and
next time it's gonna be even easier
because you're most comfortable around
yourself just like you said right
yeah yeah exactly 100
and um
because of that reason because
i would say focus more on on your
private life because like i said
naturally naturally you're going to be
you know
good a good boy or a good girl whatever
and i've i've known people bro yo can
you say that one more time
uh the last line the good boy good guy
yeah whatever
good boy good girl yeah because you're
you're naturally gonna be a good boy
good girl in public you're not gonna be
that person in public but in private you
know
like you said before you feel like no
one's watching you right and that you
fall in that ignorance say but just in
private know focus on that and try and
make that your your time to really
thrive and and do your best because um
that way and this was gonna mention
before that way there's no possibility
as for it it's for anyone else
because there's benefits there's pros
and cons if you do good in public you
can motivate other people to do good but
you could also you know
uh become arrogant and be like you know
i look good in front of all these people
i just gave charity you know i look good
in front of people i just i just prayed
salah and in public and no one else is
bringing salah you know and they could
become an arrogant thing and you might
not be rewarded all by allah because
your intention became misguided but when
you private it's easier to sin it's
easier to sun but you know in fact
you're doing it for the sake of allah
and no one can come and say oh you're
doing it because there's a bbc camera
watching you and broadcasting or
anything like that
uh anno was talking about uh brother
khalid when he was asking oh isn't it
better to be passed in public and anh
was clarifying that we're not talking
about not being pious in public but
we're talking about specifically being
pious in private and look at the title
of the stream guys look down below it
says being solid and private that's
that's what the main thing is about and
the monaficon the people that are
hypocrites these are the people that
when they're out there with people the
camera's on them they're solid when the
cameras are off behind the scenes
you only know what they could be up to
so
you know yeah yeah bro and i've i've
heard
really quickly sorry i've heard of
people bro who like they seem so pious
bro they seem so up there they seem so
like they care about dean and they're on
dean and everything
and they'll even have the quran on their
page and everything and i've heard
stories from from sisters saying that
what this guy dm me and he was saying
this and then he messaged me and he
like
these these things bro and it's like
may allah
[Music]
it reminds me of uh
and not to throw anyone under the bus
but you know just to say the truth here
uh it reminds me of a lot of the
issues that born muslims have
it's like in public they'll put on
the the front and they are muslim
but they pray that they do all this
stuff but then when they're in private
they don't
and
the biggest repercussion from this is
like
you're playing
you're playing with allah like you're
playing with your akira your afterlife
and like you're playing with your own
iman
it's like you
your belief
if if you're not sincere in private like
your belief will suffer
and if your belief suffers like
you don't think that it's gonna get to a
point where you
enter a state of disbelief
where your heart is so stained
by these marks that now you just you
don't even believe anymore and then you
you become
you become atheist you become whatever
it is that you think
is now the right way but you only became
so because
you were out of alignment
yeah
brother yama writes again allah will not
forgive people who stand publicly we
should be very careful not to simply i
mean 100 percent like sinning and
publicly sitting it publicly sending in
public becomes very easy once you start
doing it's slippery slope kind of like
xena so
i advise all of you all to be careful
with that
comments again
people who boast about their good deeds
publicly
the good deeds will be worthless on the
day
[Music]
you don't let the bad get to your heart
you don't let the good get to your head
it's facts
that's really good
sad thing this might not be relevant to
the podcast but
uh
i don't know if you guys always knew
this right but me being a born muslim i
only found this out like a year ago two
years ago but
juma for men we know it's mandatory it's
obligatory right
but a lot of people they don't they
don't know it's obligatory there's
countless hadith to to you know discuss
that there's no excuse
right so
bro they were they were discussing like
the process i'm telling men to walk like
distances that you could not even
imagine and today all we got to do is
take a 5-10 minute break from work sneak
out you know
and
i'm not saying you know everyone has
their excuses everyone has their their
exceptions but jamma is an
obligation for men
i'll say this one more time jummah today
if you haven't gone to germa if you're
not planning on going
to obligation do your research look it
up uh consult your sheikh don't just you
know take me for it
but it's an obligation you can't just be
at home chilling when it's friday as a
man
you know there's another
reminder yeah there's another hadith
that if if men
um yeah anyone that going to jummah if
you
take a bath hustle you clean yourself
you purify yourself
um there's another condition too like
you were you know you wore some nice
clothes and you walked the gym or
something like that um
i forgot what it was but every single
step you take
is going to literally like bring you
closer to jannah
and you know so very beneficial another
super chat from
ali knitting is something old men should
do now
if it keeps them away from haram man
it's better than falling into harambe
man prioritize um things that are better
for them
better than doing a lot of things in
private with your hands so
he's not wrong about that uh next we got
another comment from brother khalid you
guys are making sense is that claire for
the response a similar comparison to one
of the signs of the last day that the
mosques will be grand and large but are
empty
that is true that is true i think rami
said there's going to be another sign
that there's going to be a lot of
speakers but a few scholars
[Music]
i'm kind of already there
huge shout out bro i guess we know which
subscribers are the subscriber of this
stream you know you know how they have
employee of the month
brother ali is subscriber of the stream
um
and you're from london ontario
like what is london ontario yeah i'm
like thinking in my own life with london
i know what ontario is down there from
london is this is this some kind of like
thing about what for us sahabi was
saying well like you're bringing two
concepts together and making it one yeah
it's the middle point between london and
ontario
there's like a little island right i'm
just kidding bro we have a place called
london ontario
come on bro don't do this bro everything
here it's from like you know when when
europe conquered here it's like we have
a place paris right here we have a place
london
essex
you know so aren't you all like aren't
y'all controlled by the french or like
dominated by the french yeah that's
funny man that's funny bro i don't know
about that i know wasn't that how i was
in the beginning that's why french is
like the
the main language
it's we're dominated by if you could say
britain maybe like england you know we
still follow the queen and all that
yeah
calibrates in the middle of the atlantic
ocean though
about speaking about oceans
[Music]
if you do good deeds oh i'll say this if
you sin and you think you know that's it
for you
and you
you think there's no hope for you i want
you to stop saying you know you know you
stop sinning i'm not saying don't stop
sinning
but don't think that you know you got to
work only on not sinning and you can't
just simultaneously start doing good
deeds as soon as possible asap
doing good deeds is extremely underrated
um so i got a question for both of you
for anyone watching what are some quick
good deeds that anyone can start asap or
some good quick good deeds that you guys
try you don't need to like now boast
your good deeds and say okay i do this i
do that but just some ideas that that
people can start asap
i got one right here i'm gonna go off
screen because i'm gonna read this
hadith that i saw this one i think it's
very befitting
let me know if you guys can still hear
me yeah i can bro
shout out to jasim or hasim for becoming
a member
uh so
it was
this is in sahih bukhari
2472 muslim 1914
uh it was an area that the prophet saw
allah said while a man was walking in
the road
he found a thorny branch in the road and
he moved it aside
allah appreciated his deed and forgave
him
just let that sink in so simple
simple bro
all he did was move
a thorny tony branch
so anything that we do was like
you know what
i guess like you could think to yourself
like what would i want you know like if
i'm walking and i see the neighbor's
house and they have like a piece of
trash like
maybe you wouldn't think twice of
picking that up but it was your house
would you pick it up
no you actually reminded me of the the
hadith that we mention every once in a
while of uh there are different
narrations some say it was a
a woman who was a prostitute some say it
was a man who was a sinner allah adam
but there was a person
who saw a thirsty dog
so they got water from the wall for the
dog to drink
and for that they were they're entered
into jannah
so
there are there are
these things i think are a testament to
a person's character so i don't think
that they send their whole life that was
the only one good thing they've ever
done allah maybe it was but you know i
think that just shows
their sincerity in their heart and
generally what kind of person that they
were
when they weren't committing sins they
genuine genuinely and generally have you
know a decent heart
but i would say
this is from my own anecdotal personal
experience
when i help other people
for the sake of allah
that's when i
feel the closest to allah that's when i
feel like i'm really making an impact in
all of that
but i'm not going to use my experience
and say you should go do that i'm going
to use the hadith of the process
there's two hadith one is a hadith where
the prophet says that allah the most
high has said so this is allah speaking
allah says that the most beloved acts of
worship the most beloved deeds to him
are the ones that he made obligatory the
ones that are fart so praying fasting
and all of that
and then also he says and then the
servant of allah continues getting
closer and closer and closer with
voluntary acts of good until allah
begins to love them
so
we have to make sure first and foremost
we have our father we're doing what's
obligated right
and we're trying our best not to sin and
on top of that we have to increase in
and you know voluntary good deeds and
the process that the best of these are
those which are consistent even if
they're small so you know i actually i
met this brother in the vegetables
he's a beautiful brother his name is
may allah elevate him he said
when he gives in charity he doesn't just
give you know maybe
a hundred dollars uh
you know every once in a while or
something like that he says every time
he answers the masjid he has a handful
of change and he puts a little bit
every single day every single time he
goes my budget he puts some change
in the in the charity box in the zakat
box
and it's because
he's he he wants to follow the hadith
fossil syrup where it may be small but
it's consistent which means you never
stop doing it
i can like i can go to the measure drop
a hundred dollars now and then feel good
about it the rest of my life and never
do anything good again
a lot but keep it consistent and you'll
consistently get good deals yeah it was
kind of like why why go pray at 100 like
40 rakat one night and then not pray for
like a week rather you know we're
supposed to pray five times a day right
so very important stuff
it reminds me of the hadith
and i'm gonna butcher it but it's where
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said that
um you should
do
sadaka you do charity even if it's like
just the half
of a date
i just think about that just the half of
a day like look at a date cut it in half
and like even that would be enough
for allah to forgive you of your sins
or to erase your sins
my kids go to an islamic private school
also ranked up school not in mashallah
that's a very very good decision
he's saying donate
you should do a podcast about women who
keep children away from their fathers we
have so many problems about it here in
dk it's a huge problem man we'll bring
gabriel back to that one inshallah yeah
that's that's crazy bro
a lot of women weaponize
intimacy and marriage this is like a
common issue right if you don't have
kids like they'll be like oh you know
but don't use that because you know they
know that's something you need um but
there's there's another level of
degradation in in someone's just their
spirit bro how do you keep someone's
kids away from them
just you know it's
you know who would have a lot to say on
this but the people don't want to see
you
yeah
yeah i don't know exactly who
yeah
people people don't want to see him but
but he says what's neat what needs to be
said in that regard and and i think it's
important because today
when you look at family law
it's extremely matriarchal it follows
the you know favors of women family law
and divorce law and alimony settlements
and and you name it anyone that goes to
law school they know exactly what i'm
talking about
um islam is not not you know for the man
for the woman it's for fairness for
justice
yeah
that's very true
dk is done mark yeah bro i got what you
mean i was about to say i didn't know
what dk was though sounded like donkey
kong i was thinking oh you were thinking
donkey kong too bro yeah
yeah subhanallah
what's my email love what your brothers
are doing marshall bro
bro take a screenshot of that
i mean it's on the live now so you can
uh you know do your thing you take a
screenshot
okay now
there was
one thing that i've heard from uh
you know
nastia sessions regarding sitting in
private but i got a question for y'all
um i don't want to just say don't sin in
private and then leave it at that be
solid and private but
what are some i know this is gonna be a
very difficult thing for a lot of people
to talk about but what are some of the
common sins that people commit in
private today
the youth young adults even older adults
like what are things i know every sin is
easier to do in private but what are
some special ones that people are
falling into now for both of you guys
too that you've seen because people are
dming us right people are asking us for
nasiha what do you guys commonly hear
and and definitely let's not get this
video demonetized so uh
you know just just definitely you know
use some uh
elegance in your vocabulary
okay
so using
do you know what else
not hating their prayers not hiding
their prayers oh majorson
he basically said that there was a
saying that a man and a woman isn't
alone except that shaytan is the third
person in the room
this is huge or like two people aren't
alone except the shaytan's you know the
third
um
isn't it also isn't that also with allah
so these are two different hadith the
first hadith is that a man and a woman
are not alone together except that
shaytan is the third and there's another
hadith that says there isn't a group of
people of muslims who get together for
the sake of allah
there isn't like two muslims that get
together except allah is the third and
there aren't three to get together that
allah is the fourth and there aren't
four they get together that allah is the
fifth and and
if they make mention of me
and they're in their company and their
gathering allah will make mention of
them in the gathering even better it's a
beautiful hadith
i i mentioned the context of the first
city dimension not to show that allah is
not there allah is always there but
in the context of
the one that's there to make you sin
allah doesn't make you sin but shaytan's
always trying to make you sin
the another
from kaleb also thought he came in
donkey kong too bro we had the same
childhood man come on now brother ali
writes again i hate to say it i hope no
one takes it the wrong way the reason
men can't see their kids and muslims
divorcing and fighting because men are
taking a less
role in their marriage and the woman
bigger yo this is facts bro yeah
that's facts
see in the west we have
in and i want you guys to watch an
episode that we dropped a recent episode
episode 102
with uh sheikh uh faris al-hamadi
we talked about gender roles and
differences between men and women but
there's no equality there's no
partnership there's no like you know two
emirates of the household two imams of
the household no this is this is not
islam you know we're not seeing men or
women better than women now i don't want
all the sisters out here to dislike and
and do what y'all did to gabriel
and god this brother demonetized them
what i'm saying is
islam is a patriarchal religion in the
sense that men have authority right not
not that we oppress women or anything
like that but we have authority and this
is clear-cut unapologetic right so
there's no way around it so what brother
ali is writing
is that's true bro you look around in
muslim marriages um bro subhanallah
there was a guy i wanted to uh hang out
with him one of my boys this was like
years ago bro and i was like yo can we
uh can we go here tomorrow let's go
let's make it happen he's like oh i
gotta ask the missus i'll get back to
you
i mean even though he phrased it i mean
like you know i have to check with my
wife is one thing but like i have to ask
it's like
like
it's one thing if he's like
bro instantly i was try i was like i was
still not deep into islam and you know
males having authority being mirrored
and all this back then
but i still had in my fitrah to be a
little bit confused and and at this ease
so i asked him i was like oh why do you
have plans with her he's like no
like that that's even worse the fact
that you don't have plans with her but
you're like i gotta ask her yeah yeah i
mean i don't want to go too far off
topic but i mean if you think about it
just in general women in society are
being put up here and told to stay up
here and told they are authoritative
they are powerful they are you know
men are being repressed in society
that's why that's why it seeps into the
household that because like if you bro i
find it hard to find a sister or find a
woman i'm engaged in something that
right but like other than that i find it
hard to find a woman who isn't like
when you become
like when you really speak with them
that they don't have this kind of like
like oh i need him to respect me like an
authority kind of thing there's so many
sisters that are like that and there's
so many brothers that are like bro like
a lot of the time they're just kind of
chill they're kind of you know
they just kind of chill guys they're not
looking to be like you know i need her
to to respect me and need to know that
i'm authoritative and all of that
because it's honestly it's been reversed
but that's that's off the topic
i agree bro there's a lot of comments so
let's get back to them but what i'm
saying is hundred thousand million
percent facts that
is already working against you
so what do you think your kids are going
to see when they see daddy's weak and
mommy's strong and daddy's pandering and
you know it's it's it's like bro
nothing's worse than
you know
your kids asking you for something and
you saying no and they're like okay cool
i'm gonna go ask mom now and mom's
saying yes
mom basically not deferring to your
authority not respecting where you had
to put your foot down but basically you
know when they have that secret
relationship where it's like oh don't
tell dad about this stuck for allah bro
stuck for allah well this makes me want
to make the whole episode about this now
man yeah facts i will save it next time
haseem or jasim forgive me for my
ignorance for pronouncing your name
wrong how can i maintain my iman at
night i would have considerable level of
man but when i wake up in the morning
it's like my mindset has completely
changed can't pray fajr with full
concentration
what do you think of
earlier wake up earlier usually
i have the same thing if i just wake up
just for fudger
then like
the prey is just not it's not legit and
it'll only probably get legit like once
i finish the prayer
and i might i'm just making dua at the
end
but like if i wake up earlier and i just
kind of like
maybe sit in reflections and meditation
maybe read a little bit before hitting
my prayer oh
you got tahajud too bro yeah
yeah
it's very good answers from allah just
to add to that if you look at the term
iman people translate it as faith amen
doesn't mean faith iman means rational
conviction that you you have um not just
a belief but you you accept a fact
that's based on evidence of reality so
the more you learn about islam and the
more you prove it to yourself the more
iman you'll have like literally uh so
learn more about islam it'll increase
your mind
i think we're seeing that a large
portion of us men are avoiding
responsibility accountability in
marriages this is true
let me hit this let me hit this real
quick so it's it's what i want to say
for the previous thing
that you guys were talking on and it's
the fact that like
getting married is such a huge
responsibility
and fire cannot vouch for this because
he is married alhamdulillah
and rami he's about to get into it so
alhamdulillah like he can vouch for this
but
me myself i think
and i only know a little bit from
jahiliyyah but it wasn't marriage so i
can't say that oh i know what it's like
to be married
but i have an idea of the amount of
responsibility that comes with it
especially if you want to keep the
dynamic strong
especially if you want to be the man if
you want to be daddy in this
relationship and you want the woman
basically to be mommy
you know so it's like
there's so much responsibility and it's
for brothers out there that have no idea
what the responsibility is this is where
you can seek other brothers that are
strong in their
in their deen and their strong and is
dynamic in their relationship even years
into being married you can see what
they've done you can get there and i see
her and then also just being ready for
whatever
responsibility is thrown at you that
allah subhanahu wa allah throws at you
because it it reminds me of um this
thing that
during our class i think it was like the
the second or third class that we were
taking
in a i3 institute
where
brother farhad
may allah bless him
he had said uh
being muslim
being muslim
with
along with being muslim comes great
responsibility but with responsibility
comes
great accountability
so it's like not only do you have to be
responsible
but you also have to hold yourself
accountable
for
adhering to that responsibility
i agree
that's very true yamada it's ali
you are very right but as a man in
europe you can't do much about it if
your wife if your ex-wife decides to
keep your kids away from you because all
the laws are for women and for the man
it's zero this is facts
isis agrees let's see we got another one
uh yama rights west is making our women
more and more
or
feminine
and more feminism and and our our women
are falling for it you can't even say
anything to your wife because they will
just call the police on you so many
cases i know but that's that's true
the best way to avoid it just marry the
right woman honestly yeah
we're vetting this is where vetting is
super important
vetting is reading is key um if you're
if you're with you know if your woman's
not acting in line with how you view an
ideal muslim what to act
you're either bad with woman women or
you're with a bad woman
i always say this but if you're bad if
you're with a bad woman do what what the
the fellas right here just mentioned
pick the right one to begin with
if you're
bad with women i'mma share the the the
hadith that i that i shared in uh in the
episode with brother faris for the 11th
he mentioned that if i disobey allah i
reckon the effects in the behavior of my
wife and the camel i ride
and bro when i when i first heard that i
i like thought up you know reflected on
that for like a good 10 15 20 minutes
and it's really profound because what
you do
it really does sometimes project in your
life
now there's hidden barakah there's
hidden blessings that we're not aware
that allah blesses us with right and it
could just be that when you when you sin
and you you you know you're not on no
fap you guys know what i'm talking about
and you're not doing things you're
supposed to be doing
these badaka these blessings they get
stripped away from you
so now it's like it's in the open now
because you you realize that oh
everything's working against me
everything used to be you know with me
now it's like an uphill battle but it
could just be that and subhanallah that
we even have this level of feedback
mechanism from allah that when we're not
on the right path
i don't know if it's the fitra i don't
know if allah is giving us signs but we
usually know we're not on the right path
at least for a bit before we get
desensitized to doing the sin over and
over so subhanallah that allah has even
given us the quran has even said
rasulallah saw
has even given us revelation time and
time and again has even given us the
perfect blueprint to live our life
yet we're choosing not to live the right
life like how does that make sense
that's very true subhan allah that's
very true
yeah we got 15 minutes left i think i
say we uh open the the chat to
public no yeah and while we're doing
that in sha allah say if you wanted to
comment before you wanted to join the
discussion the lovely brothers and what
they were mentioning before and the
discussion we were having but you
couldn't it's because you're not a
member so lives
remember only yes please
uh if you want to join that chat become
a member insha'allah yeah a lot of
people see you and it helps us
i agree a lot of people think they can't
even see the stream if i say member only
no what does member only mean bro
member only means that you can only
comment if you are a member
as far as i know that's basically it
to not see but comments
yeah
and what do you know this stream got
demonetized
it did already
well yeah we said stuff we shouldn't
have
i'm not bad
until next friday where we will try this
one more time
it's okay
it is what it is
now demonetized you're still making
money it's just making less money
yeah whatever it is what it is you know
what we said is more worth
whatever
and at the end of the day guys once
again for all of you guys i think when
we make money we're out here buying you
know
expensive cars or flying and you know
doing random trips and just chilling no
like we have a masjid fund
we're in sha allah we can build a masjid
with the money we have from our major
fund in the next year and we'll keep you
guys on the journey very transparent
with you guys um we give a lot of
sadhaka we try to make a livelihood when
we have more money from youtube that
just shows that we can do more dawah
we're not trying to take the money in
you know
i was about to say a joke but then i
realized like you know what
we shouldn't joke about these things
yeah that's very good
that's good someone knows susan isn't
happy i see that's funny
i think i think
i think there's bro if it was susan
that's one thing but i feel like the
youtube algorithm it just automatically
like just flags videos that you know
why i like
allah
do you guys have studying skills with
prayer
do you mind elaborating on that bro yeah
i don't know what that means
chad
adam khan bro i see you commenting bro
all the time man lamela bless you bro
loyal t3m supporter
i don't like to use the word fan bro
this is so shitty you know yeah that's
cringy man yeah like youtube has a super
fan and all the i don't know bro
okay the last thing you said brother
fight is so true when i sin everybody
around seems upset with me subhanallah
yeah it might not be that
your life gets worse when you sin
but it might just be that allah is
blessing your life to be better
and it just returns to equilibrium or or
just ground zero allah is not making
anything more negative right
so it's kind of like when you're not on
point you notice that the blessings that
allah has been giving you they're just
not there anymore so relatively it feels
like you're you're declining which you
are but allah is not making your life
worse
allah is just might not necessarily be
allowing you to have the barakah to make
your life better and it's good that we
have this feedback to show us to you
know course correct and get back in our
lane and do good
it reminds me of that dude you sent me
uh
he's not a muslim but he would say that
any time that he would
basically play with himself yeah that's
like he would be punished by god
yup yup all these no fap and and you
know
seed retention youtubers
why am i even censoring my speech if the
video's already demonetized because
y'all i don't know but maybe it's a good
source of habit that you might want to
pick up on anyway uh yeah the youtuber
basically said that he said that when i
play with myself when i touch myself um
i feel like you know
the most high because i don't think he
was theist or at least definitely not
muslim
um he would say that i feel like you
know the universe is just against me the
most high is just punishing me
okay
okay question why can't some people join
as members i click the link oh you're
probably living in a region where
membership is not available to you it
could be that
uh i don't know what else it could be
yeah i'm not sure to be honest
when your brother is doing a video on
women and makeup
psychology oh i know i know who's gonna
go in on this
i can't i can't recommend
any yet
i'm still too new to reading them to be
able to recommend them
yeah me too
bonded by shahada there we go that's
that's that's the only bond we need
mo elaborates on his previous question
about studying skills in prayer which we
didn't really get the first time he says
i'm a college student and it's hard for
me to balance prayer studying work okay
uh my two cents put prayer first put
allah first everything else comes into
place you try to put everything else
around prayer it ain't gonna work bro it
ain't gonna work buddy
yeah
salah is the easiest of those those
three so allah is just a few minutes
work and studying school and all that
is something else so i would recommend
as soon as the prayer comes in make it a
habit as soon as a prayer comes you drop
whatever you're doing you go pray
maseratis
what do you mean when you say
accountability in marriage accountable
bro by allah allah gives you
uh obligations in marriage for example
providing for your wife
that's not sadaka jarea that's not like
an option you know i know in the west
they have these weird things where man
stays home watches the kids wife goes
outside provides none of that in islam
you are accountable to provide for your
wife
i don't care if she's a millionaire i
don't care she has no money for basic
expenses you must be willing and capable
of providing at the very least even if
she wants to do more you must be willing
and capable
uh you know that's one another one you
must be willing to protect and provision
put your life on
men
i
need to go
is 1206. i need to eat and head over to
jummah
bro
[Music]
if you guys don't know i'll probably put
a link in the description uh because too
many people are watching people dream of
mubarak i don't know what that is but
yeah
take care bro enjoy your journey yes
have a good day bro
i'll take care of you yeah
yeah anyway that's that's basically that
and then for women obeying your husband
that's that's that's a that's an
obligation
obviously you know in in parentheses
provided he's not telling you to do
something haram right
i want to start wearing those beanies on
her where's the man single-handedly
brought them back into style
that's about a lot bro
so true may allah bless you guys may you
reach millions soon insha'allah
inshallah it's only possible through
your support and to allah first and
foremost
inshallah thank you my guys
and bro i feel you trust me like i'm
married
i'm in med school
and
i'm you know here running the podcast
and doing everything else that i'm sure
the other brothers can feel with a heavy
workload
and it's possible bro there's don't let
anyone tell you that you got to pick and
choose you know what i mean like
they were sold this lie that everything
comes at an opportunity cost and yes i
do agree
but taking an opportunity cost for the
sake of allah putting allah first if
that means you say no to something else
that's never going to burn you on the
day of judgment that's never going to be
something that you resent
that's always going to be something
that's going to weigh in your favor
um
so i mean some of it is just what i you
know what i hear online when i listen to
lectures and when i read and all of that
but uh most of my knowledge
alhamdulillah especially like the basics
and the really really important stuff
comes from the i3 institute so it's the
letter i the number three institute dot
ca they have a yd a young daiy course a
young dai program it's free it's two
hours a week and it's honestly it's
amazing i'm actually teaching that
course now
for two classes but it's it's really
great masha'allah so i recommend
everyone to go to i3 inshallah
and i'm a student in odami's class
and you know wallahi rami did not tell
me to tell you guys this uh he didn't
you know this was not planned or
anything but um i'll say it right now
martial and may allah bless him that
the way he teaches it's very different
than than school than university than
than college because i'm currently in
grad school right now and and i know
that he teaches in a way where it's like
open learning it's like discussions it's
not closed-ended facts and dates and and
different names of the sahaba radhila
nothing like that it's very open and you
learn a lot so definitely you guys
consider i3 and make the world that you
get paired up with army as your as your
teacher
i'm trying to fight laziness against a
lot before laziness creeps in
fox
big fan from dubai
we just talked about that term fence
we got we got we got family bro
okay
so what do you tell people who say we
can't change anything in this world
tell
where every every single person
in the literally in the ummah at that
time was trying to say the quran was
created they're trying to argue that and
imam ahmad was the only one who was
saying the quran does not have a creator
allah did not mention it
it has been created or anything like
that so where are you getting this from
he was put in prison he was beaten he
was tortured but today we don't have
anyone saying the quran is created and
if they do we know that they are not
muslim
tell them to yusuf al-assam who was
locked up in prison and when they said
that you know we can we can modify this
so we can we can make your name good and
we can we can get you to sneak out he's
like no
i only want to come out when my name's
been cleared like having sabar in allah
it's key bro many people lack that today
but yeah
leading them back to your question
someone allah just just have faith in
allah don't worry if you know the main
question i'll ask you guys is the
question that fed us is a hobby
asked us when you know he came on our
platform
if you were the last muslim today would
you still be muslim yeah
oh that's it's a loaded question right
because a lot of people hear that
they're like man how do i know i'm not
the last muslim
or maybe it's easy to say that because
you're not the last muslim today but
imagine this there's no other muslim
except you but you know it's the truth
just like today you have full conviction
would you still be muslim
and in sha allah the answer is yes
these questions are very important to
ask because i feel like when you pass
away you know how the first three
questions we're going to be asked um
who is your your rob your lord
um who's your messenger what is your
theme and if you can't answer these
questions
um you know
it's not going to look much better for
you if you can then everything's easy
for you and then you know the first
thing you're going to be asked about is
your salah your prayers complete and all
that we're not talking about that but
these these questions you can't really
prepare for them like
intellectually
they're there in your in your in your
heart and your soul
in in in the unseen in the right right
because
even an atheist
you can tell them that you know there's
going to be this test and the answer's
going to be this but on their judgment
the heart speaks and they're not going
to be able to say and produce what i
just said so
essentially may allah put it in our
souls in our heart not just in our mind
because it's easy to just know the right
answer to the three questions
yeah
i mean it's very true
there are
major sins and minor sins
what about saying to offer protection
before entering the house bathroom and
eating it's better for you to seek
refuge from allah to protect you from
shaytan alone i mean it's very true
question oh no where'd you get your
first quran before you accept islam
i'm not bro i'm not in here so maybe
next time
i think i think it was actually gifted
to him from one of his friends but it
was sitting on his shelf for a few years
ended up yeah a long time
is it me is it me who's freezing all the
time
oh no it could be me bro because my
battery's at like eight percent oh it's
fun okay is it is it bad or is it still
doable that was good it's good enough
in a marriage are you responsible for
the sins of your wife again i'm not a
spoiler so i can't tell you this um but
you are responsible for for the very
least what i know guiding her to the
right path making sure that you you as
the amir as the imam you're making sure
everyone's straight that that's your
responsibility yeah yeah you should
follow the quran
says that basically if you're your wife
is disobeying someone like sins doing
haram you have to advise her kindly keep
advising her keep advising her and if
she doesn't listen you have to leave the
bed um and if it gets to a point where
you have to divorce then you know it
could go down that route but allah's
best
could you put the name of the institute
yeah guys type in i3 i for indigo and
then the number three institute
and uh we'll be sure to remember
inshallah to put in the description
anyone wanting to give charity there's a
live campaign for refugees on yeah the
more you know subhanallah
i sympathize with mo i work full time
take 12 credits per semester and work
out i try to make it work though gang i
feel you bro
okay let's see
will i face racism in canada if i keep
long beard uh luckily luckily from i
think that's the bangladesh flag it's
not you guys by the way i am bengali i
don't think i don't know my flag i know
the flag is the green flag with the red
dot but i'm so far from the screen that
i can't even like see that close because
my setup the way it is so i literally i
know someone's gonna be like bro this
guy's been gone he doesn't even know his
own flag you know i just i'm way too far
from the laptop right now i could barely
even like read the text
uh yeah
the last phrasa be pakistan diet and
lifestyle
uh was really good someone's pockets are
really high i agree bro
harami you remind me of sheikh mohammed
tim humboldt may love bless you and
protect you
that's that's an honor honestly because
i i love that brother
that is an honor man miller blessed him
humble man muslim since he was 14.
okay guys we're gonna do a few more
questions and i'm gonna quickly end this
stream because we reached the one hour
mark
uh join us next friday where inshallah
the topic is gonna be
self-fulfilling prophecies
self-fulfilling prophecies being when
people just believe in their own
i guess
ideologies even if it's not necessarily
correct it's like an echo chamber very
important and uh just remember you need
to be
a member to comment on on any of our
videos on on like a member to comment on
the live streams participate in the live
chat
but you will still be able to see it and
then at the end for a few minutes just
like now we open it to the
public to love this no you don't want to
pick and choose as a female
what does that mean picking juice
i love your content managing work masha
allah can you make more podcasts
i'd love to have both of them on
uh messaged me last night something i
literally completely even forgot to
reply so jazakallahu for reminding me
but i'm definitely going to reply now
saying you know
so let's make it happen you can hop back
on and then inshaallah may allah bless
him
was was attacked by some uh some idiot
to be to be honest
and recently and alhamdulillah you know
there was no i guess damage or danger to
his health and he wasn't harmed everyone
was fine but he did tell me that the the
attacker was also someone that attacked
someone in their masjid before it was
the same guy so you know
be steadfast in the in the path of allah
don't fear death and inshallah you won't
fear anything
i thought rami is the king of intimacy
how can he be engaged right now well in
islam the only intimacy you can have is
with a spouse so that's why he's engaged
right because there's going to be no
intimacy if you're not engaged or
married um well definitely no intimacy
if you're engaged but you know
without being married so
how can you be the king of intimacy if
he's not on his way you know
exactly i'm just i'm just getting up on
the throne now inshallah
okay two more questions
how do i take a path to learn islamic
knowledge i found one course but one
issue i face is payment
again i3 institute the letter i
the number three
institute.ca sign up for the yd program
the young daii program two hours a week
completely free and it is an amazing
institution honestly i would say
probably one of the best institutions on
the feeds of the earth um that's not me
just you know blowing smoke it is
genuinely probably one of the best
institutions on the face of the earth
right now
well you know they will uh
love you for loving us for a sake i mean
i mean
all right guys and with that being said
just remember
the takeaway from this video
it's easy to be solid in public when
everyone's watching but
it also matters what you're doing when
no one else is around you and no one
else is watching because allah is always
watching
so give yourself that self-respect that
you deserve and always be solid when
you're in private as well i mean
i mean
that's it
and all that being said
allah
foreign